we all know that apple is the world's
largest company the world's most
profitable company and arguably the
world's most revolutionary company but
did you know that apple is also one of
the most indebted companies
as of june 2022 apple had 10.9 billion
dollars in outstanding commercial paper
14 billion worth of short-term debt and
48.8 billion dollars in other current
liabilities they also had a total of
94.7 billion in long-term debt and 53.6
billion dollars in other non-current
liabilities all of this adds up to a
total of 222 billion dollars worth of
debt given apple's insane profitability
and their massive cash reserves you
would think that apple would pay off the
dead asap but they've actually been
doing the exact opposite over the past
several years apple has been
consistently taking on new debt if you
take a look at their total liabilities
over time you'll see that they've 10x
their debt over the past decade and just
a few weeks ago they raised another 5.5
billion dollars at the same time apple
has also been vigorously reducing their
cash reserves since the beginning of
2020 apple has reduced their cash
reserve from 107 billion dollars to just
under 50 billion dollars so while apple
is indeed more profitable than ever
before they're also more leveraged than
ever before with a debt equity ratio of
over two so why in the world does apple
have so much debt
starting off with the reasoning that
applies to not just apple but all of us
we have the economic reasoning by this
point i'm sure all of you guys are well
aware of how high inflation is in july
we saw the inflation reading peak above
nine percent and in the most recent
inflation reading we saw inflation come
in at eight point six percent people are
hopeful that this decline means that the
peak for inflation is already in it but
even if that's true we're likely going
to see elevated inflation readings for
at least another year so it's smart to
leverage strategies that benefit from
high inflation and one of those
strategies is taking on more debt now at
first this may seem a bit
counterintuitive when inflation is high
the cost of production skyrockets which
makes it difficult for companies to
maintain their margins so
psychologically the last thing you'd
want to do is add on more debt and take
on yet another regular payment but in
the long term this is actually the best
time to be taking out debt you see if
you lock in a loan today your payments
themselves will be the same for the
entire duration of the loan however this
cannot be said about the value of your
payments with high inflation the real
value of each payment will be
consistently declining paying a thousand
dollar mortgage in 1990 is not the same
as paying a thousand dollar mortgage in
2022. the 2022 mortgage is far cheaper
despite being the same dollar value
companies are able to take this idea to
even the next level because their debt
generally works differently from the
debt that we're used to for example with
a mortgage you'll be paying principal
and interest every single month interest
does make up a larger portion at the
beginning and a smaller portion near the
end but regardless you're paying
interest and principal with every
payment with corporate debt however
companies generally only make interest
payments for the duration of the debt
and it ends not till the end of the term
that companies pay back the principal
now this might not sound like a big deal
but it is and here's why
let's say apple took out one dollar
worth of debt in 1970 at a three percent
interest rate for 30 years
interest rates were obviously not that
low in the 1970s but that was the last
time that we saw inflation at these
levels so that's why we're using this
time period
anyway this would mean that apple has to
pay 3 cents per year in interest which
works out to a total of 90 cents over 30
years this is quite a substantial amount
given that the interest itself is nearly
equivalent to the initial loan value of
one dollar but despite this apple would
actually come out ahead by quite a
margin you see apple didn't have to pay
back the initial one dollar till 2000
and by that point one two thousand
dollar was only worth 23 1970 cents so
essentially apple borrowed a dollar and
only paid back 23 cents you would of
course also have to factor in the cost
of the interest but the point is that
apple comes out on top by a large amount
considering this you might be asking why
in the world would anybody loan apple
any money when they know that apple is
going to come out ahead well the answer
is that the lender's alternatives are
even worse usually the people that are
lending these companies money are banks
pension funds and conservative
individuals who are retiring soon for
these people stability and liquidity are
extremely important so they can't just
go out and invest in stocks
so really they only have two options
which are to either earn three percent
from apple microsoft and other large
corporations or earn half a percent from
money market funds and cds or maybe two
percent from treasuries and from this
perspective taking the three percent
deal is a no-brainer so really it's a
win-win scenario apple gets cheap money
and while lenders get the best returns
they can without going to equities
[Music]
as you can see borrowing money at low
interest rates during high inflation
itself is rather profitable but apple
isn't going around and borrowing money
just so they can turn interest rates
honestly that's probably not even worth
the hassle for them the main reason
they're borrowing so much money is to
actually deploy it in areas that produce
greater returns for apple specifically
this seems to be in two areas starting
with stock buybacks if you're not
familiar with stock buybacks this is
essentially when a company goes onto the
stock market and buys their own shares
this not only increases demand for apple
stock but it also reduces the supply of
apple stock you see it when a company
buys back their own shares these shares
become what is known as treasury stock
at this point companies do have the
right to sell these shares back on the
market if they wanted to
but more times than not companies decide
to retire these shares which basically
means to remove them from the supply
permanently over the past several years
apple has been buying back record
amounts of shares almost every quarter
they've been buying back 15 to 25
billion worth of apple stock which just
reduces supply of apple stock
substantially within the last 10 years
the number of outstanding apple shares
has fallen from 26 billion shares to 16
billion shares this is one of the main
reasons that apple has been able to
continue growing their market cap
parabolically despite already being so
large aside from funding stock buybacks
another reason apple has so much debt is
to fund their dividends for the longest
time apple didn't actually pay any
dividends because they couldn't afford
to but starting in 2012 apple started
paying dividends and they've been
aggressively increasing their payouts
ever since their dividend payout has
literally increased 10x over the past 10
years now you might be wondering why
borrow money to pay out dividends well
the first thing to establish is that
apple does not need to borrow money to
pay dividends they just choose to and
the reason they choose to is to make
their stock more desirable here's the
thing even a company like apple can only
grow their revenues and profits so much
iphone sales peaked years ago and the
only reason apple has been able to
continue growing their numbers at an
insane rate is thanks to their high
margin services last quarter for example
service related profit accounted for
nearly half of their gross profit even
though services don't even account for a
quarter of their revenue so services
have really been their cash cow over the
past couple of years but sooner or later
that's gonna start leveling out as well
and at that point appeal of apple stock
would be lower than ever
now this is not a bad thing given that
all companies eventually get to decide
of the s-curve but in the meantime most
companies buy back stock and pump up
dividends to slot on this process as
much as possible
with the economic and technical
reasoning out of the way we have the
fundamental reasoning for taking out
debt honestly this isn't super
applicable to apple today given that
they're already past the growth phase i
mean it's not like apple needs to borrow
money to build a new factory or develop
the next big thing now technically apple
does spend a significant amount in both
of these areas but it's not like it
really grows the company all that much
for example they recently built a
billion-dollar campus in austin which is
great and all but it's not like it's
pivotal to their growth but just because
they can't use debt to fundamentally
grow themselves doesn't mean that they
can't use debt to fundamentally grow the
company as a whole the main way they
accomplish this is through a bunch of
acquisitions now this might be a bit
surprising because you almost never hear
about apple acquisitions on the news but
this isn't to say that they don't do
acquisitions they actually do a bunch of
acquisitions the reason you don't hear
about them is because apple stays away
from all the hot companies that you're
familiar with instead they buy several
background companies every year usually
for a few hundred million each in 2017
for example apple completed 12
acquisitions in 2018 they completed 10.
in 2019 they completed six and in 2020
they completed nine and that's just the
ones that are listed on wikipedia
according to apple insider apple usually
completes between 15 and 20 acquisitions
per year
usually these acquisitions help them
advance their current products or
develop new products for example in 2020
they acquired an ar company called
kamurai and a vr company called spaces
these acquisitions support the rumors
that apple will be coming out with their
own ar and vr products which will of
course help the company continue growing
fundamentally they're not limited to
just buying startups either they can go
out and buy stock in their partners or
even competitors if we take a look at
apple's balance sheet we'll see that
they have 131 billion dollars in
long-term marketable securities so it's
very possible that a portion of this has
gone towards buying the stocks and bonds
of other fortune 500 companies
technically apple does not need to
report a stake in a public company
unless it's larger than five percent so
apple could have a hundred billion
dollars taken microsoft and the 50
billion dollars taken tesla without
having to tell anyone knowing apple
though they probably avoid these popular
companies if they do have stakes in
public companies it's probably in a
background company like qualcomm while
we don't exactly know what these
investments are as these investments
grow so does apple's balance sheet and
at that point it's just a matter of time
until that growth is reflected in their
stock price so it's more than worth it
for apple to use debt to fund their
investments
in the end while apple is more leveraged
than ever before it's not exactly a bad
thing because it's extremely strategic
it's not like apple is taking on credit
card debt at 20 interest rates to buy a
new tv
rather apple is taking on debt at
historically low interest rates to
better navigate high inflation while
also pumping up their stock price both
technically and fundamentally and
honestly this is a brilliant way to
protect the long-term future of the
company and its shareholders with that
being said though apple does have to be
careful because there's a fine line
between smart debt and stupid debt and
it's not that hard to end up with too
much debt that ends up weighing down the
company i mean have you ever heard of
2008 so though apple has been playing
their cards well so far they'll have to
keep a close eye on the situation to
make sure it doesn't get out of hand but
that's just what i think would you be
willing to loan apple money comment that
down below
also drop a like if this video gave you
a different perspective on that and of
course consider checking out our discord
community suggests future video ideas
and consider subscribing and see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one
[Music]
you